it's the site that everyone here has
been waiting for the cost of concordia
upright again off the coast of giglio
stained by rust and badly damaged the
vessel has survived the ambitious
salvage operation without breaking apart
exhausted salvage workers returned to
dry land in the early hours of the
morning to a hero's welcome I've been
fantastic for the last 20 months assist
the least we can do is try and help them
out of the situation the operation to
rotate the capsized wreck took 19 hours
time-lapse footage shows the vessel
emerging centimeter by centimeter from
the water engineers used a system of
cables and steel tanks to lift the giant
ship and in a feat of technical prowess
turn it by 65 degrees and the rotation
happened the way we thought it would
happen and the way we hoped it would
happen it was a perfect operation i
would say for the residents of giglio in
particular the relief is immense hagonoy
it's great news we've done it of course
we'll remember this event but it doesn't
matter now it's over but Giulio will
have to live with the Concordia wreck
for some time yet efforts to tow the
ship to port for scrapping aren't due to
start until next spring